on the day of the start of his trial for
impeachment this was the divorce
diversion President Trump on the world
stage in a place surrounded by business
leaders where his advisors knew he would
look presidential it's clear from his
recent comments and his posts on Twitter
that the u.s. leader is obsessed with
impeachment but this was a speech over
half an hour long in which the i-word
wasn't mentioned once today I'm proud to
declare that the United States is in the
midst of an economic boom the likes of
which the world has never seen before
we've regained our stride we discovered
our spirit and reawakened the powerful
machinery of American Enterprise
America's thriving America's flourishing
and yes America is winning again like
never before many of the world leaders
who were in the room know how much now
depends on the u.s. electorate this
could be Trump's and last stavos
but they're preparing to for the
possibility of a second term this is a
global forum dealing with global issues
and so we have more and more conflicts
breaking out across the world that need
everybody around the table to solve them
and we need the United States as part of
that conversation and the United States
needs an effective State Department it
needs an effective diplomatic core and
soft diplomacy as well in order to be a
true partner and I think people are
genuinely worried this is a place where
Donald Trump feels comfortable
he was never invited to speak at Davos
as the head of the Trump Organization
now he feels part of this elite club as
the US president his advisers cleverly
using this as a backdrop for a speech to
a domestic audience James plays out
Azera Davos